- [DRock] You wanna
kinda update me on...?
- The day?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- Normal day. Busy.
That's my update.
- [DRock] Cool, are who
are these lovely people
that we're about
to go say hi to?
- I don't know.
(DRock laughs)
("Monday To Monday" by Saba)
Saba, I've been telling you.
("Xiro" by Okiem Warmann)
I'm gonna make this
a binary conversation
of either you
believe in me or not
which will be good for us.
- [Man] Yeah.
- [Claude] We
haven't planned it out.
- [Gary] The dollars impact
and just the brainpower for this
and really to understand what
this actually even means to that
was something that
I think made it go that way.
We have a lot of work to do.
We have to like
build the database.
- [Man] Right.
- But, we're there.
In a real way, it's really cool.
And it's actually gonna be
majorly impactful
on our business.
And it will work
and you're right,
three, instead of one,
that's how we're gonna win.
We're gonna walk in and say hey,
you're making us pitch
for this video (censored).
Let us tell you something,
we're gonna give you two, real
big ones that are (censored)
straight up,
here's a (censored) video
that they thought
they'd pay (censored).
So, we'll say that,
you're gonna get six micros.
Don't forget,
everything's a chess move
for us to be the full monty.
You know every day that goes by
gets more and more intriguing.
We'll get bigger.
We do this right.
That's it. That's the
gospel religion, every second.
Okay.
Such a pleasure.
- [Woman] Likewise.
I'm gonna hit you
with a little water.
- Moisture.
("Understand" by Bazanji)
Good to see you.
- Good to see you.
- How've you been?
- How have you been?
- Really well, great
to see you, my friend.
- Thank you for the time.
- Of course.
It's this new generation
of I'm just gonna give my
bubble gum startup to 45
influencers on Instagram.
- [Man 2] Sure.
- It's a million here,
three million there,
nine million here.
- [Man 2] Sure.
- Six million here,
two million there.
- [Man 2] And at
2% growth, it's done.
- In parallel,
they're gonna continue to
grow their
private label business.
- [Man 2] Mhmmm.
- Continue to squeeze
you for more brand dollars.
It's not sustainable.
- [Man 2] Right.
- [Gary] See you tomorrow night.
Real pleasure. Great to see you.
I remember the conversation.
I'm ready to rock and roll.
- [Man 3] Ready
to rock? Alright.
- Yeah, give me context.
What can I help with? Yes?
- [Man 4] Our
context is basically...
- What I'm saying is
you need to hack culture.
What does that mean?
That means that if
this is your religion
of building this business, that
when the women's march happened
you guys would sit
there and go, "Holy shit!
"There's a women's
march happening in two weeks."
Right? As it happened
a couple weeks ago.
"Can we play?"
And you may say we can't.
We want to stay
away from politics.
It doesn't matter.
Your mindset as
a strategy team is
we can do something some day
that will fundamentally
change our business.
- [Man 3] Right.
- And people don't do that.
And it's not smart.
It's Ben and Jerry's.
Like all the
companies like Godiva,
they've all had
historically these moments.
The Pepsi Challenge.
La Croix sparkling
water with the girls wearing,
that's actually an Instagram.
You have to think that way.
If it's your mindset,
it's your mindset. Got it?
- [Woman 2] 'Kay.
- You can't be a digital brand.
You need to build a business.
("Relevant" by Blake)
- [Man 5] What's up, Gary?
- [Gary] 'Sup man?
Great to see you.
- [Man 5] Good to see you again.
How you doin'?
- [Gary] How you been?
- [Man 5] Good,
really good. How are you?
- [Gary] Hey!
- [Jacory] Jacory.
- [Gary] Corey?
- [Gary] Jacory, Gary.
- [Sam] Sam.
- [Gary] Sam. What's up brother?
- [Sam] Pleasure to meet you.
- But if you can
hit scale, like I have.
- [Man 5] Mhmmm.
- Then you've
got ungodly leverage.
- [Man 5] Yeah. But in
case you haven't noticed,
you're in this office and
everyone else in New York isn't.
- Yes, but guess what?
I was in some shit hole
conference room seven years ago.
Like, you got to decide
how good you are in this.
- [Man 5] Yeah, yeah.
So, do I roll the dice
and maybe on the other side
I'm disappointed.
- You know what I'd tell you?
You know what I would tell you?
- [Man 5] Yep.
- Actually, 'cause I didn't know
how to answer this. I'd probably
tell you to go through it
so that you come out
the other end with knowing.
'Cause otherwise
you'll never know.
- [Man 5] Mhmmm.
Yep.
- But the space is right.
This space is the
realist space going.
You just have to figure
out how talented you are
and were you early
and got the benefit.
- [Man 5] I feel like
I started this before it came.
I got on this before
it became the trend.
As big of a trend as it is now.
- My man--
- [Man 5] It wasn't 10 years ago
but it was right
before it really took off.
- That's what you think today
and some kid that
looks like you that
starts today is gonna say the
same thing to me in 24 months.
Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 247
of The #AskGaryVee Show.
- [Q] My name Swardick Muyanda.
I'm from Woburn, Massachusetts
but everyone calls me Q.
Just like the letter.
- Alright, Q, I got a
very important question.
- [Q] Please.
- Are you a Patriots fan?
- [Q] Of course, I'm a
Patriots fan. I'm sorry--
(group laughter)
- Alright, Q,
I had to do it to you
but I promise you that I will
call you back another time.
I'm just not in
the mood right now.
I'm still bitter.
- [Woman 3] My question is,
I wanted to know
since you're all about
inspiration and everything,
I've been feeling a
little bit unmotivated
and I've been feeling like
I should be doing something
or I should be...
I feel like I
should be pulled...
I'm feeling uninspired,
basically. That's my question.
How do get, when
you lose inspiration
or you lose motivation,
how do you get it back?
- [Gary] I get it
back by remembering that
you might die tomorrow.
- [Woman 3] That's true.
- [Gary] So I'm
inspired by practicality and
reality and the truth which is
it is ridiculously impossible to
become a human being.
("Relevant" by Blake)
Hello.
- [Man 6] Hi.
- Yeah.
- [Man 7] Go through
what we sold them or do you want
to talk about the tech piece?
How do you want to position it?
- I'll go fast here.
- [Man 7] Okay.
- I really want to understand
the tech piece because
in the short term...
If I strategically said,
(censored) are worth million,
then we just adjust, right?
- [Man 6] Yeah. Yeah, I mean but
then they need to be...
- Alright.
- [Man 6] Thank you.
- Cool. Thanks guys.
Thanks Jeff.
- [Jeff] Thanks guys.
- [Gary] I have other
good things going for me
as a human being
and I'm just grateful.
Your dwelling and
looking at what you don't have
versus looking at what you have.
If you actually
looked at what you had,
your health, you know,
living in America,
who the heck knows
what would be on your list,
if you actually spent
all your time looking at that
versus I don't
have a million dollars.
I'm not famous.
I don't have this.
If you spent all
your time on what you have
versus what you don't have,
you would be the
happiest girl on Earth.
The rest of the world
is going to critique you
and judge you.
You need to stop
doing that for yourself.
("Relevant" by Blake)